it appears you out of options tell me
about the threat known as inferno
professor Langdon we need your help
three days ago a man killed himself we
think it was part of something much
bigger there was a package in his pocket
and what was it
it's Dante's Inferno they defined our
modern conception of Hell 700 years ago
but these circles of Hell have been
rearranged why Dante why this map of
Hell Dante Dante's death mask yes we've
got to get to Florence
I need access to Dante master that the
mask is no longer here it was stolen
here's the security footage professor
that looked like you I have no memory of
taking that map you did I just saw you I
want to know what I'm involved with why
was someone shooting at you everything
is out of focus professor you are having
visions aren't you the people behind
this would do anything to protect the
truth you have no idea what they're
capable of this is what I have been
seeing look look this is not in the
original painting here's another one
prophecy oh my god Dante's Inferno isn't
fiction it's a prophecy someone created
a plague our population is spiraling out
of control Inferno is the cure they're
gonna wipe out half the world's
population unless we find this virus
they left a trail we will be able to
trust your own thoughts for a while
human life at stake so plague exists you
know more government for you to get it
the professor has become a liability go
let's get it
there's always way out it's nice to have
you back professor if this plague is
real we only have 48 hours to stop an
extinction-level event I will do
everything I can to find it
Dante's in fun not day to find our
modern conception of hell
700 years ago why don't they